[Music]
I am terrified of that moment when our
last one leaves for me it's like if we
just keep having babies then at some
point sure for sure I won't have to
experience that but I think the morning
I think that's what you meant to say
though this is fun we had about eight
years to where we kind of thought we
were done with new babies and we were
raising the four that we had yeah crew
really just something about him was
almost like a parachute you know at the
end of a race car you know it just it
didn't it didn't force us to slam on the
brakes in the negative sense it allowed
us to really stop and and I will say
it's just like we notice things about
him that we might not have caught on the
first four crew has like really
done something to me where I'm typically
just go go go I have just wanted to kind
of set back and say I'm going to look
for these moments of Wonder because this
is what my four-year-old toddler has
taught me it's been this beautiful uh
season to where we've got these four
older kids that treat this little boy
the way they love on him and and Big
Brother and big sister him and these
sweet ways everyone's been a gift in so
many ways and watching him like just
damn it do it again do it again
well the renovation power Duo might not
be expanding their family at the moment
but they are expanding their portfolio
after eyeing a Waco Texas castle for two
decades and three failed offers chip and
Joe are restoring this historic property
on Fixer-Upper the castle streaming
Friday on Magnolia network HBO Max and
Discovery plus was there ever a point
where you're like chip why do we need a
castle
um for the last 20 years he's been
trying to buy the castle he got to the
point where he wouldn't tell me anymore
when he was putting an offer friend
because I said I don't want the castle
don't buy the castle it's uh it's hard
we're still working through this clearly
the irony is that the only time I could
have actually have afforded it was the
time it actually was accepted and now
here we are you know but the other three
opportunities probably would have
bankrupted us the plan for the castle is
to bring this beautiful property back to
its original state how long did this
project take
this was our longest project by by a
long shot it was fascinating it was
fascinating this thing took on a life of
its own and it took longer it took more
money I would say that's partly why
we're so proud of it now that it's on in
the rearview mirror but during the
project it was exhausting and and three
years
we planned a year of design research
um figuring out where we can get the
materials and then once we finally push
go it was almost a year of construction
the cotton Land Castle was built in 1890
and took 23 years to complete so you can
imagine restoring the 6 700 square foot
home without losing its unique character
was quite a challenge it's over 100
years old so was there ever a point
where you're like
we're getting out
yeah I walked in the door first 25 of
the project
um I had to call Warren Buffett about
two-thirds through it and ask him if I
could borrow a little bit of money
because we there was nobody I knew Rich
enough to get us across the Finish Line
I would say this is more like zero steps
forward 12 steps back that's what it
feels like what was the scariest part of
doing this the exterior stuff like the
stone was the scariest decision for me
because if you mess that stone up you
know it's like it's like it's like a
facelift going wrong more than it being
on Fixer-Upper more than anything we
wanted the neighbors to be proud of what
we did with this thing it turned out
great we're proud proud of it this is a
way bigger renovation than we
anticipated we are keeping all the
paneling we've got to fix this plaster
work what do you want to do with the cat
what's going to happen there's two
different answers here okay okay you're
at a y in the road on the Castle's uh uh
future go ahead I think we sell it yeah
um why not we bought it to sell it that
was the intention right so what do you
want to do with it no idea I don't think
Joe and I want to live here literally
but when I think about owning a piece of
History like this is history and wake I
mean this is a project that I was
pursuing for 20 years the reality is we
need to sell it and we should sell it
but I wonder if it's not one of those
things 10 years from now you don't look
back and wonder gosh
if somebody in the family wanted it
would you rent it out well would you
Airbnb it this neighborhood means so
much to us I think it would be a
disservice to the neighborhood if we
turn this into kind of a commercial
entity in that way when we bought this
place it was a figment of our
imagination but now this house is coming
together
[Music]
you're coming up on your 10-year
anniversary um for Fixer-Upper wow I
don't even wrap paper like so I need to
stop and celebrate that do you know we
need to find out like the date for that
and specifically because she got a phone
call production company and I thought it
was like a scam but this thing was real
and this world of people now that they
they feel like you are their family
you're chipping Joanna to them that
means a lot it does and it and it feels
good but I I don't think we knew that
going into it you know it's hard to
believe that Joe and I just being who we
are connected with people in that real
specific way
[Music]
foreign